JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS,
DANA PERINO, "THE FIVE"."
BERNIE’S FIRST, MAYOR PETE IS
SECOND, KLOBUCHAR IS THIRD.
POOR LIZ CAME IN FOURTH BUT IT
WAS A PHOTO FINISH.
>> ALL EVIDENCE SAYS THAT
ELIZABETH WARREN HAS FINISHED
OUT OF THE MONEY.
SHE HAS FINISHED FOURTH.
SHE IS STILL AT WORK.
ELIZABETH WARREN, WHO LIVES JUST
TO THE SOUTH OF THE STATE OF
NEW HAMPSHIRE IS TAKING A
PICTURE WITH ALL WHO ASK.
SPIGOT THIS ISN’T LONELY TO ME,
THIS IS AWESOME.
I LOVE IT.
>> SHE IS A REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY GOOD CANDIDATE.
>> Greg: GREAT, SHE IS ON HER
WAY TO BECOMING A WALMART SANTA
AND MSNBC IS SO SUPPORTIVE.
THEY SOUND LIKE YOUR BUDDY AFTER
YOU GET DUMPED SAYING, DON’T
WORRY, THIS OTHER FISH IN THE
SEA.
BUT YOU MIGHT JUST TAKE A
PICTURE, SHE WILL TAKE YOUR LAST
$3.
>> A YOUNG WOMAN CAME UP BY
HERSELF AND SAID I’M A BROKE
COLLEGE STUDENT WITH A LOT OF
STUDENT LOAN DEBT, AND SHE SAID,
I CHECKED AND I HAVE $6 AND THE
BANK, SO I JUST GAVE $3 TO KEEP
YOU IN THIS FIGHT.
THAT’S WHAT WE’VE GOT TO DO.
>> Greg: THAT’S WHAT WE’VE GOT
TO DO, TAKE AFTER YOUR MONEY.
TYPICAL DEMOCRAT, WITHOUT A
THOUGHT.
JOE CAME IN FIFTH.
LIKE THE TIME I STAND AT TABLE
WITH A CHEAP VARNISH, IT WAS A
DISAPPOINTING FINISH.
YEAH, THAT JOKE IS EVERY BIT AS
BAD AS JOE’S CAMPAIGN, SO WHAT
DID WE LEARN?
AUTHENTICITY RULES, EVEN WHEN
YOU’RE WRONG ABOUT EVERYTHING.
POLLS SHOW AMERICANS WILL NEVER
VOTE FOR A SOCIALIST BERNIE
MIGHT’VE DONE MORE TO ELECT
TRUMP THEN TRUMP.
LOOK AT THESE NUMBERS.
CALLING THAT A WIN IS LIKE
CALLING THE CORONAVIRUS THE
SNIFFLES.
WRIGHT, CHRIS?
SPIGOT THEY JUST WANT TO BE
SECURE IN THEIR OWN ECONOMY, IN
THEIR KIDS ONCE IN A WHILE.
IF THAT IS THE CASE, TRUMP IS
GOING TO BE TOUGH TO BEAT, SO I
DON’T KNOW.
IN EITHER CASE I THINK IT IS
TOUGH TO BEAT TRUMP.
I AM A BIT FRUSTRATED, AND NOT
THE ANSWER TO ALL QUESTIONS.
I’M JUST NOT TONIGHT.
I’M A LITTLE FRUSTRATED.
>> Greg: SOMEBODY GET HIM A
THERAPY CHICKEN.
AS FOR JOE, HE SAID YOU CAN’T
WIN AN ELECTION AS A DEMOCRAT
UNLESS YOU HAVE OVERWHELMING
SUPPORT FROM BLACK AND BROWN
VOTERS APPEARED WHAT DOES THIS
MEAN?
IT’S A KNOCK AGAINST MAYOR PETE,
THE MEDIA SAYS HAS A BLACK VOTER
PROBLEM.
I SUPPOSE IF THEY WERE WHITE
CONSERVATIVE VOTERS IN THE MEDIA
WOULD JUST SAY THEY ARE
HOMOPHOBES.
MEANWHILE, TRUMP MAKE IT THE
MOST BLACK VOTES FOR A
REPUBLICAN IN A LONG TIME
BECAUSE HE HAS DONE GOOD FOR
BLACKS, CREATING ECONOMY THAT
FAVORS ALL CITIZENS.
THE DEMS SAY THE BLACKS ARE A
VICTIM OF THE PAST AND WE ARE
GOING TO GET YOU DAMAGES AND
THEN THEY DON’T.
REPUBLICANS SAY YOU WERE GOING
TO DO GREAT RIGHT NOW AND I’M
GOING TO HELP YOU.
AND HE DOES.
WHICH ONE SOUNDS BEST TO YOU, TO
BE VICTOR OR VICTIM?
THE DEMS KNOW THE ANSWER.
NO WONDER CHRIS IS MISERABLE.
SO WELCOME BACK DANA AND JUAN.
VERY LONELY WITHOUT YOU TWO.
>> Jesse: I THOUGHT IT WAS
ROOMY.
SPREAD OUT.
>> Greg: JUAN, I SAW YOU IN A
PICTURE THIS MORNING WITH WHO I
BELIEVE IS THE REAL WINNER.
THERE YOU ARE IN THE MORNING
WITH AMY KLOBUCHAR.
IS THERE SOMETHING WE SHOULD
KNOW?
>> Juan: YOU KNOW, LOVE IS IN
THE AIR APPEARED AT THE
VALENTINE’S DAY.
I WOULD LIKE TO JUMP ON THE
BANDWAGON.
SHE IS ROLLING.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU THINK THE
RESULTS?
>> Juan: FOR SOMEONE LIKE
SENATOR KLOBUCHAR, I THINK YOU
REALLY HAVE TO LOOK AT THE NEXT
TWO STATES.
DOES SHE HAVE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE, THE ORGANIZATION
ON THE GROUND?
AND I DON’T THINK SHE DOES.
THE REASON I SAW HER AT THE
AIRPORT THIS MORNING WHEN SHE
WAS ON HER WAY TO NEW YORK FROM
BOSTON, TO RAISE MONEY, SO SHE’S
GOT TO GET SOME MONEY IN THE
POCKET IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
TO ME, A LOT OF THE STUFF IN THE
MONOLOGUE I WAS THINKING ABOUT,
YES, THERE IS A LOT OF
INFIGHTING AMONG THE DEMOCRATS
RIGHT NOW BUT I THINK THAT
DYNAMIC SHIFTS ONCE YOU GET A
DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE.
WE HAVE SOME POLLING THAT SHOWS
MOST PEOPLE NOW THINK TRUMP WILL
WIN.
AGAIN I THINK, YEAH, PEOPLE SAID
THAT ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON BACK
IN 2016.
EVERYONE SAID, YEAH, HILLARY IS
GOING TO WIN THIS, DON’T WORRY
ABOUT APPEARED TO ME, YOU CAN
EXTRAPOLATE FROM AN INTRAPARTY
FIGHT, JOE BIDEN LOOKS LIKE
HE’S GOING OFF THE RAILS, WE DON
WE DON’T KNOW WHAT IS TO COME.
I WILL SAY HE DOESN’T LOOK GOOD.
MY DAD WAS A TRAINED BOXER AND
HE WOULD SAY, SON, YOU BETTER
GET YOUR ASS IN GEAR.
SO I THINK THAT IS WHAT’S GOING
ON WITH JOE BIDEN.
BUT HE DOES, UNLIKE KLOBUCHAR,
HAVE INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
GROUND COME INSIDE CAROLINA AND
EVEN LEADING ESTABLISHMENT
DEMOCRAT OFFICIALS IN NEVADA.
OF THINKING HARRY REID, THE
FORMER SENATE MAJORITY LEADER.
>> Greg: IS THERE HOPE FOR JOE
JOE?
>> Jesse: NO, I DON’T THINK
SO.
HE’S HANGING ON BY HIS
FINGERTIPS.
I DON’T THINK HE HAS WHAT IT
TAKES TO PULL IT BACK TOGETHER.
I HATE WATCH MSNBC SOMETIMES --
>> Juan: WAIT, YOU DID NOT.
WHY?
>> Jesse: BUT AFTER A FEW
MINUTES I REALLY STARTED LIKING
IT BECAUSE THEY CAN’T STAND ANY
OF THEIR OWN CANDIDATES.
>> Dana: DID YOU SEE THE PART
WHERE THEY WATCHED THE
LIVE STREAM OF JOE BIDEN FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA AND THEY
ABSOLUTELY TRASHED IT?
I SAW THAT PART TOO.
THEY WERE LIKE, IT IS SO BAD.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS THE BEST
PART OF THE NIGHT.
THEY WERE MAKING FUN OF THE
FRONT RUNNER AND THEY JUST
COULDN’T HOLD BACK.
MAYOR PETE HAD A GOOD NIGHT.
BUT YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF, IS
AMERICA READY FOR THE FIRST GAY
PRESIDENT?
I AM, BECAUSE I’M VERY
OPEN-MINDED.
BUT I DON’T KNOW IF THE REST OF
THE COUNTRY, NOT TO MENTION
MILLIONS OF DEMOCRATS.
BERNIE SANDERS IS A RADICAL
SOCIALIST TO HONEYMOONS IN
MOSCOW.
HE CAN’T LEAVE THE COUNTRY, HE
CAN’T EVEN UNITE HIS OWN PARTY.
HE IS TOAST.
BIDEN IS RUNNING ON FUMES.
WARREN’S PRETTY MUCH TOAST, AND
THEN YOU HAVE KLOBUCHAR, WHO
GAVE A GREAT SPEECH LAST NIGHT
BUT SHE DOESN’T HAVE THE CASH TO
GO THE DISTANCE.
AND YOU ACTUALLY THINK AOC AND
THE BERNIE BROS ARE GOING TO LET
MANY MICHAEL BLOOMBERG SWOOP IN
WITH ALL THAT CASH AND WRENCH
THE NOMINATION?
NO, THE DEMOCRATS ARE COMPLETELY
PANICKING RIGHT NOW.
NANCY’S RATINGS ARE DOWN, CNN’S
RATINGS ARE DOWN.
AT THIS POINT IT LOOKS LIKE THE
MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATS, ARE
CREATING TRUMP SUPPORTERS.
LOOK AT THAT TURN OUT LAST NIGHT
IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, BROKE RECORDS.
SPEAKING OF WHICH, ANOTHER
STOCKMARKET RECORD TODAY, GALLUP
SHOWS AMERICANS ARE RICH, HAPPY,
AND CONTENT WITH THEIR
POCKETBOOK SITUATIONS.
NOW THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO ASK
THEMSELVES, WHO ARE WE GOING TO
LOSE WITH?
BECAUSE WE’RE NOT GOING TO WIN.
IS IT BERNIE OR BUST?
THAT IS WHY THEY’RE PLAYING
NICE, BECAUSE THEY KNOW THEY’RE
GOING TO HAVE TO BROKER IT IN
MILWAUKEE BECAUSE NO ONE WANTS
TO SAY ANYTHING MEAN BECAUSE
THEY MIGHT WIND UP ON THE
TICKET.
>> Greg: THAT IS IN PRETTY
PERCEPTIVE STUFF.
>> Dana: I MISSED EVERY BUDDY
VERY MUCH.
GLAD TO BE BACK.
>> Greg: WE DID TOO.
I JUST FELT MORE ANALYTIC.
>> Dana: I THINK THAT FOX NEWS
DID AN INCREDIBLE JOB OVER THE
PAST TWO WEEKS.
ALL THE COVERAGE, AND I THINK
THE COVERAGE OF THIS DEMOCRATIC
PRIMARY IS VERY FAIR AND
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE ARE
WILLING TO SAY SOMETHING IN ONE
OF THOSE IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
REALIZE THAT IN NEW HAMPSHIRE, A
LOT OF THE PEOPLE THAT SAID
THEIR FIRST CHOICE WAS BIDEN,
THEIR SECOND CHOICE WAS NOT
AMY KLOBUCHAR OR MAYOR PETE.
IT WAS BERNIE SANDERS.
SO THAT MAKES ME THINK THAT JUAN
MIGHT HAVE A POINT.
IF IT IS BURNING, THERE’S A LOT
OF PEOPLE WILLING TO GET ON THAT
BANDWAGON, BUT IF
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG TRIES TO COME
IN, AND I DO NOT SEE THE BERNIE
PEOPLE EVER COALESCING BEHIND A
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG CANDIDACY.
>> Greg: I’VE NEVER ACTUALLY
SEEN ANYONE GET ON A BANDWAGON.
I’VE NEVER SEEN A BANDWAGON.
>> Katie: WE SHOULD BANDWAGON
AROUND NEVADA.
>> Greg: THAT WOULD BE FUN.
>> Katie: THAT WILL BE FUN.
YES, FOX SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN
AMAZING BEING AT THE DIFFERENT
RALLIES AND THE DIFFERENT
CANDIDATES.
THEY WERE GREAT, THEY WERE SO
GREAT.
PETER DOOCY, EVERYBODY IS DOING
AN AMAZING JOB.
IT’S INTERESTING TO SEE
AMY KLOBUCHAR’S RISE, AND THE
QUESTION IS, WILL THIS GIVE
ANYONE MOMENTUM INTO
SOUTH CAROLINA CUSTOMER
SOUTH CAROLINA VOTERS AREN’T
NECESSARILY GOING TO CHANGE THE
NEW HAMPSHIRE BUT DONORS AND
PEOPLE WHO DEAL WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE PAYING
ATTENTION.
THAT IS WHAT YOU MAKE LITERATURE
IS A NEW YORK RAISING MONEY, I’M
SURE MAYOR PETE IS STILL GETTING
A LOT OF PHONE CALLS, ASKING
HOW THEY CAN MAYBE GET SOME
BIDEN DONORS, OR MAKING THOSE
PHONE CALLS, FIGURING OUT HOW
THEY CAN HELP THEM, WHERE DO YOU
NEED THE MOST MONEY, DO YOU NEED
THIS, THIS, HOW ARE WE GOING TO
THE DELICATE FIELD HERE?
BUT BERNIE SANDERS IS ON A ROLL
AND FOR THE LONG TERM, PEOPLE
NEED TO START THINKING ABOUT
WHERE WE ARE IN THIS MOMENT
BECAUSE AS AOC SAID AT A BERNIE
RALLY LAST WEEK, DECADES OF
ACTIVISM IN THE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, GOING BACK ARE PAYING
OFF TO THIS MOMENT AND IT’S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND IT’S NOT
GOING AWAY BECAUSE THE MAJORITY
OF BERNIE SANDERS FANS ARE YOUNG
PEOPLE AND I DOUBT THEY’RE GOING
TO CHANGE THEIR IDEOLOGY SO AS A
COUNTRY IT IS IMPORTANT TO POINT
OUT WHERE WE ARE, AND TWO
DIFFERENT SETS OF HOW WE RUN
THINGS AND GO ABOUT LITTLE
DIFFERENCES HERE.
THERE IS A COMPLETELY DIFFERENT
SYSTEM.
BERNIE SANDERS WASN’T
HONEYMOONING IN THE USSR WHEN IT
WAS SOCIALIST, HE WAS THERE WHEN
IT IS A COMMUNIST COUNTRY.
IT IS STILL COMMUNIST TODAY, SO
I THINK CALLING HIM A SOCIALIST